citizens of the reject Nation it is time
today to watch Wonder Woman
Bloodlines which in the continuity I
follow means we get some Zoo sculpting
from clay definitely you learn all about
her Heritage coins family tree it's a
Ken Burns documentary also hit that
subscription Bell if you haven't already
hit that like button so I know that you
like this very video and leave in the
comments which origin you follow for
Wonder Woman because I'm always very
curious and while you're there
commenting let us know which one of
these you want us to watch next as we
dive deeper into the
dcautcamudc Universe DC e-u-d-c I don't
even know anymore leave a comment
yelling at me about labeling this very
video wrong I know today I am groovy koi
I'm ready to get bloody how are you sir
I'm good um I'm thinking of bloody this
would allow you to cover your blood it
is a bad first shirt if you got punched
in the chest repeatedly and you're all
bloody and you want to hide it boom bad
for sure you know who gets punched in
the chest a lot Batman you two can hide
that bruising and pretend be a
billionaire playboy philanthropist and
do it in style look very swaggerific
yeah when you visit our
shopzeroedition.com store how else you
can be squaggerific you can head over to
the patreon to become a super sexy
reject and dive right into there to
watch us watch this in its entirety
beginning to end front to back and our
resting faces
head on over to the patreon to become a
super sexy reject now without further
Ado let's watch Wonder Woman bloodlines
[Music]
this is Captain Trevor at fortnite we
got modes of transportation we got boom
tubes we got we got Jets we gotta chase
I'll take it Lieutenant are you seeing
what I'm seeing copy that sir we've got
incoming
black Adam's here
I'm so sad they shaved his James Cameron
goatee I know I just I don't connect who
is this man who is this Steve Trevor
but nightmares like that
that's why you shaved
it's a fire frankly it would have caught
wait didn't hear any
team's timeline five years ago five
years ago yeah that's why he hasn't
grown yet he's younger that's right
that's what it is it's lack of goatee
confused me he still needs to visit the
abyss does he grow at four one woman
little
you know it's PG-13 show like I'm gonna
careful
first couple minutes of the video
demonetized it's crucial
this looks like heaven and you're
an angel you're still lightheaded from
your injuries I'm Diana but I'll still
take the compliment oh
just calm down
great reaction you are safe here on the
mascara home to the Amazons ruled by my
mother Queen apolita saved by a princess
is there a problem I mean traditional
gender roles don't tell Twitter
Steve's a real man it's all healed wow
what is this thing the purple healing
Ray that's your hand
what is it called the purple healing
ring
some kind of alien demons are invading
the earth look nobody knows about these
creatures and I've got to warn them you
will be held in the cells of Justice
until my mother in the Senate can decide
your fate it's not Justice lady you're
gonna put me in jail I haven't done
anything no no no no no you can't I need
to get back I have to warn them this is
the future the woke mob wants
jail him for being a man blonde white
male traps for being a blonde
gravest crime of them all oh who does he
think he is his Land of Women your next
coin frankly can't keep it up I think my
mother has proven hospitality is not her
priority
yeah princess what brings you here
unfortunately this
breaking them out Stephen Trevor of
man's world I am here to take you home
but shouldn't we be headed that way
nope once we get to the boat I can take
you across the barrier and back to your
people Point me toward the boat and I
can take it from here I saw the demon
that killed your friends and destroyed
your craft you need my help too right my
mother taught me that an Amazon does
what is right no matter the cost Diana
I didn't mean it like this not so
literally and not you I mean like
generally a Amazonian we'll pick one you
will return that prisoner to his cell
you will thank me for my mercy and we
will never discuss this again
pause
go wait in the car Stephen
I've sworn to return him to his people
and I intend to go with him if you wish
to steal from the Amazons you will have
to go through their protector it's what
you taught me
[Music]
it's fun how they animate with them
using like Z figurations like the Snyder
uh directing yeah
oh yeah spicy
if you leave you will never become Queen
are you truly willing to throw away
everything you are for the mere chance
of helping them you put it like that
oh
[Music]
oh Double Down
it's me again mother
this is great so far it's strange that
you should be my own daughter and yet
someone I do not recognize anymore you
raised her right yeah Pride it's okay
she'll come around before she like dies
tragically or something yeah
oh
don't let her see you cry turn away
Robin Wright Penn Big Girls Don't Cry Oh
sorry Robin Wright 2021 when this was
made I believe that's right that's right
how do you how do you leave this for
Superman I mean I know he's Superman but
like this is adorable yeah five years
ago you already forgot about James
Cameron it's not fair man Justice for
Cameron it's not right
so long why don't I hear sweeping if I
sweep anymore my arms are gonna fall off
he's an actual literal princess is
coming here if your arms fall off it is
a small price to pay oh my god did I
check the expiration date on the
Potpourri
one day makes all the difference a
princess
yes but you should call me Vanessa I
mean Diana right
young Daphne's confused too
[Laughter]
I know Velma says drinking
references there
um
why don't I show you the rest of the
house
I know how you feel I have a strong
mother too make her your Apprentice what
will you dedicate your life to I don't
know killing teenage vampires yes don't
worry vampires aren't real I wasn't
worried and they are
in fact I got a guy you should meet
about that you're serious I want to be
something else anything else have you
told your mother told me what that I've
suddenly allowed people to put their
shoes on the bed
I like that this is just like a family
drama yeah so there's no car chase yeah
and to establish tone there will be a
scene in a car with an argument oh I
like that yes oh dude she's crushing it
letter crush it look at that 4.0 doing
the work
[Music]
yep
knew this was coming Pete
for a second I thought she was wearing
an X-Men logo but that is an anarchy
symbol
she is getting deeper into it get that
undercut I had one of those back in the
day oh yeah well half cutter and
undercut yeah just the one side but yeah
just show them die she's really excited
what's the new fit
fresh drip
um it's totally embarrassing what's she
gonna be a superhero you can't even
drive yet
you're like a baby you
and she learns to drive are you trying
trying not in Gotham
Diane is already taking missions Julia
I'm sure I could help many by joining
you but this is the right way to help
for me then that's what you should do
what Dang thank you sisters oh I'll make
you proud whatever so what's your code
name blood lights
yes great lady
fantastic femme
oh yeah like the idea of all
alliterations for women like a great
Mercury name yeah greatness
hampered your day exactly
my grandma is there a street Trevor
goatee origin film
yeah when did he grow it the last five
years I need to know Julia it's been too
long oh where's the kiddo though summer
Tidings it's Vanessa
I'm trouble I found some disturbing
emails in her office if Dr kale read
these Veronica kale the pharmaceutical
magnet what does a drug company want
with archaeologists
our work at kale Pharmaceuticals is
valuable but I fear that it hasn't been
profitable enough for my daughter
oh boy finesse was planning to sell one
of Kale's artifacts to someone else help
me get my daughter back black market is
the most goth form of retail it's right
there in the name yeah is anyone here
hello answer me damn it it's been a long
time since anyone spoke to Dr poison
that way oh and the bride which one of
you is Dr cyber she's the one I
negotiated with that's for sure she's
keeping an eye out for us do you have
the item I want my money I need to make
sure it's viable first please show me
the money it's not going to negotiate
did you double crossed us kill her
[Music]
yes freaking gauntlets man so cool that
case belongs to Veronica kale poison I'd
get out of there if I were you here's
the agents takes the Hero
Let's Go Kill Bill time for a rematch
Wonder win
wow no giganta bigger and better
I haven't started saying that
well done James Cameron always thinking
ahead setting always thinking outside
the box real 3D move
nice I secured the artifact and I
managed not to pay for it
now that I will not allow yeah
this is an interesting choice for a
villain
I never thought I'd see Wonder Woman
fight like a giant lady yeah bigger
batter that's right how does her
saying go the bigger they are the more
they fall down yes that's it yes
that's it exactly
move Steve
thank you
wonderwood I think we can all agree
you've made some poor Life Choices
yep I love like the using the settings
to fight that the animated movies do
well
um
oh dude
story right there yeah she's
she's dead
touch me Vanessa Vanessa you'll find a
vat of chemicals to jump into you didn't
shoot Julia she didn't get hit by a
Ricochet either the angles were all
wrong I checked a dozen times I should
have been able to save her who shot her
Vanessa shot her
disgusting I had to test cheap sentiment
oh yep all the way all the way for all
time always and that's how Daphne broke
bad yep
she became the villain under the moon oh
which would have gotten away with a deer
from these meddling up
she don't know who she is I'm curious
cool with the silhouetting too
crack
we have a delivery for the doctors as
for your payment I wouldn't worry about
it
oh
she's smuggling medical equipment Tech
and artifacts she's young thinks she's
alone we need to show her that's not
true can you get us transport something
discreet I know just the thing sure you
do
what do we got oh
does it go invisible is it discreet can
we fly it through fireworks that's all I
ask
[Music]
yes
oh I love flying you never flew with me
yeah well you were flying with Superman
and there is a crowd I mean I'm not
flying with Superman now oh
get him Jim
I'm gonna show her where the hair
intertwines is all right let's rock and
roll are you worried yeah that's why I'm
not dead yet
that's good that's such a good line
I always love that moves bonking two
people together yeah it's so efficient
can it's just gonna be the hard way
I look pretty easy to me
yes yeah see hard way
sorry Steve
yeah yeah whoa
gee I drove Vibes I can handle whoever's
storming the gates I knew you were a
fighter that night in the warehouse show
me how much more you've become since
then oh boy she's not ready
all the upgrades no but she is
Expendable
wow guys Vanessa Vanessa's dead
oh damn cruel it's Silver Swan now
Silvers I do not know this character but
I'm excited to learn yeah Sam
[Music]
he's getting Archangel they are not your
friends of course they are they help me
kill you
oh Steven
Vanessa's not in her right mind the
mutilation she's endured is proof enough
of that we need someone whose only
concern is helping her a therapist
super therapist yes
security facility
cyborg speak of the devil
how about two out of three did you not
give a mouse checks that seems dangerous
yeah
like cable whoa she's being turned into
it from the inside out and it's still
going on the worst part is I can't find
any off switch or a reverse mechanism in
theory I could heal her but she doesn't
have the time and I don't have the tech
the mascara does the purple healing Ray
science if it's so easy why'd you need
to come here you out of free miles on
your rewards card I don't know where
that mascara is I don't know what a
rewards card is as soon as anyone leaves
the island they forget its location but
you're going to find it again for
Vanessa I have to oh if you promise to
bring me back something nice I know
exactly where you can start somehow
didn't expect the purple healing raid
callback yeah didn't think of all the
things that would be the thing yeah the
main plot device this was Julia's office
she always talked about the mascara
finding it was her personal Pet Project
thank you Veronica kale there are notes
in here about Medusa cells being used in
treatment I didn't even know she was
real you didn't think I was real the
first time we met uh I was concussed he
also couldn't read Perseus I mean not
doing so great
I knew about the island before she met
kale so her notes won't be on the top of
the piles they'd be on the bottom or in
the middle or between the middle and the
bottom we need a super filer yeah oh yes
this case by itself
here the Temple of pacify Fame goddess
of pacifiers
she's an oracular goddess associated
with mazes she helps people see the
future if her Shrine is still intact it
could point the weight killer that's a
cool word what the hell are we waiting
for oracular I like that word a lot
oracular like an oracle of to see that's
cool
how do you even get to a place like this
on foot not quickly
oh there she is you may have saved your
friends but you're my real Target
whoa cool you've improved
but you haven't beaten me yet
well good but I'm better
and you won't now poison and cyber have
formed irregular villains Incorporated
to take you down including me
oh a giant cheetah yes
because I'll like jackly
corporate cheetah
[Music]
it's like flash speed
Steve does any of this bother you
uh you mean the dirt no that's just a
you thing
oh we got a send Tower
yes stop
photos gave birth to the Minotaur the
Beast of the maze oh sorry Minotaur I
can't believe my eyes sent out the horse
guy a Minotaur a centaurs centaur's a
horse guy I said Centaur I meant Mana
Tower it's all good apologies comments
this is how we learn that's how we learn
yes hey Willie I found a shortcut
through your hedge maze
ow feeling a little slow
Yes actually I am whoa It's honest
what are you doing changing the
battlefield
[Laughter]
that's great
lasso stay
can't leave me like this
you know deep down what's right yeah how
does this Shrine thing work do you hit
star for customer service or you ask
politely
Choose Wisely
show me the way home
[Music]
Diana oh boy
whoa
oh snap you
I pledge my life to you Diana of the
mascara
cool
and I will shelter and protect you for
all of my days Ferdinand
yeah
the ball
an excellent Name
great my man we found this on some of
the molecules from poisoning wow
my text found our Micro stamp as soon as
We examined Vanessa's blood work
whose voice is that I can't tell but
it's familiar yeah maybe she deserves to
stay the way she is what Vanessa did she
did from pain she thinks Julia died
disappointed in her do you know how much
that can hurt
my mother could freeze ice with a look
children drinks that way
ah she might be a metahuman good line
you've talked me back to the side of the
angels I feel good Wonder Woman is like
she makes people good around her through
reason so good it's good writing the
mediterranean's so overfished certain
species have been reduced to Tiny
Pockets that mascara could be the place
where all those components meet
okay princess
which of these looks familiar
I love too that she's calling her
princess is just an actual title yeah
it's not condescending it's not like
yeah yeah it works
seek and ye shall find there's a
seamount an underwater Island how much
you want to bet it's a little bit taller
in real life
now that you've found the mascara
Dr poison and I have too how did you
access our private server uh
uh I've heard about the tech the Amazons
have it's hours for the taking killing
all of you is just good business
oh
cyber turned on the contamination
protocols the computer thinks a virus is
loose and it's been ordered to sanitize
with fire his entire floor is about to
be incinerated
uh
uh whoa swan song what a cool story this
is great I like everybody's motivation I
like the way that like the story is
developing itself yeah
personal
why does it always get worse
don't ask that because we're going into
the third act safe Trevor
you're trying to steal my power just
like you stole my mother oh your voice
is changing with the yeah
this isn't you I want this
do you it won't bring Julia back
it won't make her say she was proud of
you
guns so freaking primitive
a bomb on the other hand
Swan get out of there while she's
while she's hey wait I can't fly
oh
Jesus oh geez
you just had to wait for the dramatic
entrance didn't you
I thought you liked a little drama yeah
the poison and cyber may have declared
war on the mascara but if there's one
thing Amazons know it's how to fight a
war and fast shipping
I've always had to be ironic to order
anything Wonder Woman from Amazon yeah
does it come with special accoutrements
won't be staying for dinner Ferdinand
yes where'd you get that shirt that is a
very nice shirt on him this looks great
Ferdinand he did good work absolutely
yeah
nice it's going OG suit up
visor
[Music]
let's go team
next stop themiskira
and hopefully an Amazon who likes them
thick yeah
yeah get it
uh it's funny hook it up Diana whatever
happens there's a good chance she's not
coming back with us unless she had a
little motivation oh
you're the best Wing man wing lady
you know that's exactly the effect I
like to have on women
oh you're gonna save your own Hometown
you play your cards right they'll make
you Queen give you the key to the city
at least invitation back I stole this
armor I betrayed my own mother after you
left we fought
I turned my sword on my own mother oh
boy and Amazon does what is right
no matter the cost you mean the world to
me die I I just wish he wouldn't be so
hard on yourself
Oh you mean the world to me too
oh it's here
I know it
oh oh no
man's world has come to the mascara
make sure they do not find it wanting
let's go
I do so love mass destruction
let's hope she does too
God who's in there
[Music]
Sonic attacks like that always seem
especially harsh yeah sound hurts like
I'd be doubly painful concussive and
yeah I'm just rattling all yourselves
I'd love to get a Venom movie to like
make you feel like that like a sound
design yeah like the sound of metal but
for like Venom oh like out of Venom the
sound of venom surrender
surrender
oh
no
oh boy once that attack is ours I'm
going to build an army of you strong
enough
Mortals talk too much I love the snakes
talking with her so cool
No One controls my feet awesome my
apologies Medusa I can make you stronger
I did not come here to rob the Amazons
oh look at me wretch
look at me Hector I came to destroy them
don't stop
the money Medusa
whoa she's staying dead it's also
wondering how she could gaze upon them
without just turning them immediately
[Music]
I should still take it anywhere
this is a nightmare
it's not gonna go great
we'll just stand there
that giant statue was already a statue
I like that I don't know how one room is
gonna take her out yeah like it's fun
yeah
Gatling arrows
back
Vanessa stop you can still be healed oh
this is an eye for an eye Diana
you hurt me and now I hurt you
it's not the way no matter what you've
done I'm still with you
I Won't Let You Go
that always gets me want to run so great
no
oh no no
I got this but you don't know how to oh
I got this
I had a candy MVP Percy has killed
Medusa
I'm now I've been reading
could a mere replicant do this
we do not have to be your enemies we
have always been
Diana
I promise to turn her to Stone before I
take off her limbs well
I will not allow yeah let's go
cool
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Steve what just a gun
wow dude Steve no don't look
no
oh
I must remember that
now you got a better yeah
[Music]
ow ow
big ass snake a very special Venom it's
through almost anything it's got that
adrenaline momentum
cool yes
wolf
oh wow this girl Vanessa's just been
handed
whoa
[Applause]
gotta take your head off oh no
yes
wow that's how you pull someone's hair
but they're also snakes yeah look at me
girl
listen to me Vanessa I will not let her
harm you
no
I know you think that that you're not
enough for those who loved you I felt
that fear too
but I knew my purpose in this life and
if it is at all in my power
you will survive long enough to learn
yours yes oh
she can't see you through me
look at me first
oh
I refuse
you can't poison me with my own Venom oh
blindfold with a snake
not what I was
oh
oh you applied yourself oh whoa
damn
that was metal as hell that's hard yeah
oh
yeah wow
the princess cannot survive this she
will die if she can take the monster
with her like a true Amazon
oh earning that respect
yes
[Music]
you wanted me to choose a path for
myself Diana I choose to stand by you oh
jeez
[Music]
like ax kick keep a hand on me I'll get
you to her you do the rest together
[Music]
well done
oh like wait a second I was like how's
this myth cup yeah
oh
I'm sorry I couldn't be the daughter you
wanted
oh there you go that's a good pause you
were a true Amazon today
I know the title they gave you in man's
world you have earned their name you
truly are a Wonder Woman
why did you say that please
yeah
but I came here with the mission
will you help us
oh
purest heart it's so well written
because one of them is just good like
just this the good yeah
oh purple he like rice for everyone
everybody gets it use a little Mirror
action I'm glad they made it to Elysium
[Music]
congratulations angel
get it respect
to Diana
the champion of famous Kira you earned
it known to all as Wonder Woman
cool
[Applause]
what a great retcon to the weird New 52
choice they did the beginning this late
in the game they're like let's fix one
yeah right before the end we got one
more thing to do make sure we get it
right it is my honor to Proclaim
let the games commence yeah
yeah cool
nicely done
I really dug that one yeah I did too it
was lovely yeah I mean they they really
reconfigured who their Wonder Woman was
they really made it work for both their
continuity that established kind of like
with Superman had like they told an
iconic story but we had to get there
with the character first yeah I didn't
know this story I knew pieces of it like
this didn't feel like one storyline that
I I know but like they did a really good
job making that work yeah totally like
this had a really nice gradual build
that yeah it started really grounded and
it started you know just like kind of
like an actual movie not to say that
these haven't all felt like that and not
to say that it's bad when you start out
you know like you know already you know
hitting the ground running but I I loved
just her journey to going back in time a
little bit journeying to man's world oh
oh
she is villains I thought there was
something wrong with her why Dr kale
Julia never stopped raving about you
marvelous Amazons whose technology I
couldn't even dream of I could take it
but the only person that could find it
oh
boy you killed Julia
dang I couldn't let her figure out I was
bankrolling poison in cyber damn whoa
they successfully made me forget about
the Ricochet yeah you're your attack
failed the mascara is whole and exactly
where I left it
I'm looking forward to visiting ugh you
asked me to bring you back something
from home oh
beheadings
my mother and I are reconciled thanks to
you which means I am now officially the
champion of the mascara if you seek to
harm it or my friends you should have a
weapon
friggin boss you are not worthy I'm
intimidated amazing I'm Coming For You
Wonder Woman do
Wonder Woman I am coming for you
amazing oh that was perfect so they
removed this from the desk so yeah if in
time okay Rosario Dawson stayed okay uh
uh let's see who do we got here constant
Zimmer was Veronica kale that's what I
couldn't place okay certainly
damn
and we got some uh some Creator credits
for the characters yes as it should be
I've really enjoyed that one man yeah
and and yeah like I was saying like I
really liked going back in time a few
years seeing how she gets to man's world
and then watching this sort of gradual
build of like okay Fish Out of Water
she's being taken in she's being given
housing and whatnot and yeah making this
relationship with uh uh uh Vanessa and
her mom and all that stuff and then
slowly growing into a big superhero
Stakes kind of story from there and it
was always personal to some extent yeah
you know like it was always yeah a
personal story that then begs those
kinds of choices those kinds of moral
quandaries of like yeah how do I stay
true but also stay on the righteous path
you know and then and The Duality
between uh like betraying your family
and your family betraying you and like
you know being a good daughter and you
feeling like you know your your parents
doesn't love you like the the parallels
between her and Vanessa really
interesting because like they both were
loved by their family in ways that
didn't benefit them but deep down the
love was there and that was really
interesting to have like abusive love
because they expect too much from you in
both directions and how like when you
raise someone that can turn you like if
you don't love your kid right
if you don't give enough compassion if
you don't give enough encouragement if
you only you know try and discipline
your way to yeah to to yeah too much
expectation for both of them yeah and
even though it's not like a huge thing
you do get the sense that like
um what was her name Julia like you know
she is so
you know uh wait is there another scene
do we got another scene
no okay yeah with Julia it's like you
know she's kind of fawning over Diana
and she's you know accommodating her in
all these various ways and and it almost
seems like in in a roundabout way she's
getting a taste of that motherly
approval that she was deprived of which
that makes it all the worst for Vanessa
to have to watch that yeah Vanessa in
the beginning like genuinely caring and
just being a good kid and like seeing
that descent I really liked how maybe
more than most of them I really felt
every single person's Arc yeah like I
really bought even the villain uh the
corporate villain like I I didn't even
think I I love how good this was that I
didn't remember to think about the
Ricochet but also that I felt something
I was off about her but it wasn't so
heavy-handed yeah and then also
everyone's motivation felt real and I
love that Steve Trevor wasn't just
relegated to like you know sidekick he
still felt like he had his own Journey
but it was a very female story which is
something I also think the Patty Jenkins
first movie did well was Chris Pine was
incredible but it never was
no one got shortchanged by the
importance of like a female-led story
yeah absolutely just so happy like you
know it just kind of Hit Me part way
through of like oh this is like pretty
much all of the prominent characters are
are female and then you have Steve and
Steve isn't like a joke you know like
he's perfectly capable and he's fine
backing up Diana he loves Diana like I
like their relationship I really like
how the balance is really Charming yeah
absolutely and and it's doing all these
things without calling attention to the
fact that it's doing all these things
and it feels I don't know just yeah the
way they laid it out it felt really
natural and even the way that Veronica
Falls in with uh with Dr cyber and Dr
poison and having it be you know like
kind of rogue's gallery of female
villains again in a natural way yeah and
Wonder Woman villains certainly but yeah
just I don't know it became female
Centric in a way that I thought was like
really lovely and gradual and an
exemplary of of you know some of the
great characters that they've built on
this side of the DC
Spectrum in general and when it's like
all dudes now and notices because that's
the standard so it's nice that when it's
all women and it doesn't feel like it's
telling you it's all women it's just a
story with women like that's what I
always enjoy about like Wonder Woman is
she's just so good and when you write
her correctly like this you don't like
you don't want anything but goodness for
everyone in their life like you don't
want it like everyone that she was
fighting she wanted good for everyone
that was betraying her she just wanted
to end well and like that's the power of
Wonder Woman is like she's so good I
loved that truly yeah it seems like
truly somebody wants to leave everything
a little bit better than she found it
and who feels an immense amount of
responsibility for anything when she
becomes involved with it right Superman
like this write Wonder Woman like this
that's why they're like beautiful
opposites to Bruce as Bruce is so broken
and they're so whole and like they need
each other to understand the humanity
because it's complex yeah I I thought
this was uh one of my this is probably
my top third like this was definitely
exemplary uh I loved the villain love
that it balanced like it had like great
cheetah moment I love the balance so
many villains I love that everyone's Arc
felt Justified I loved the art style and
how it suited the Amazons I love the
lore I mean this was really great yeah
absolutely and the flourishes of Greek
mythology and stuff like that I love
that you go into the Labyrinth and you
have the minute tour it's adapted for
this context uh yeah Ferdinand I thought
that was great and uh and and two I
don't know something about the giant
effect you got giganta and then you have
a giant Medusa was like I don't know
like you know we've seen giant
characters and giant villains and stuff
before but there was something striking
about that here to me and I agree yeah
maybe it's just because it does build so
gradually and it does exist on a lot of
human scales too but yeah watching her
fight these Giants I was like yeah this
this does seem like it would be really
hard and also like it is like a very
Fantastical superheroes type of
situation and it added scope but it also
added story elements of Greek it added
that that like sense of that world I
also really like there's only one thing
that I would tweak and that feels good
that it's only one thing I would have
loved a line from Medusa like you know
you're the the champion of the mascara
you've earned my fight or something that
like why she didn't just Stone her right
away yeah and then like her getting mad
and being like bro and going to do it
and then her blinding yourself like
something to like Allah allow for that
fight to happen that long because
everyone else got turned to stone I'm
like why wouldn't she just do that to
her she's clearly looking at her face
yeah she's clearly the biggest threat on
the field something to just like an
honor or a respect you know like I'm
gonna kill you last or but like that was
my biggest flaw and that's great in this
type of Storytelling when my biggest
flaws like I'll line a dialogue yeah
yeah absolutely like this had this this
of all of them feels they've they're all
obviously they're all films but like
this this felt more like
akin to the PACE and tone of something
live action I would have loved this as a
sequel sure to the first one sure the
Patty Jenkins first one like a betrayal
of Robin Wright and she's gotta like
earn it back and like go back to the
mascara like this was so well put
together yeah yeah yeah and it's like I
love that this is absolutely you know
taking advantage of the animated you
know medium sure uh but do so yeah
absolutely and and you know the Giants
and all that stuff but uh and and like I
love the way they realize that mascara
and all that but yeah like something
this this one felt unique amid all these
dcamu movies because of the way it moved
and because of how the tone was and
because of again just that sort of
really kind of poised attention to
character it didn't seem like it was in
a rush to get to anything I like that
yeah you're right and like there's
plenty of action but it never feels like
that's the main priority and it just
feels so well-rounded and and yeah and
that you know kind of essence of
goodness emanates off of it without
sacrificing some of the harsh moments
and things like that like this was this
was like really nicely proportioned I
thought this was like yeah this was very
graceful top tier in a way I wasn't
expecting and yeah I I quite quite
enjoyed it uh so we've only got a couple
at the DC in this universe left this was
2019 it is currently 2023 as we're
recording this uh I think we've got two
you said I think this might be the
second to last one there's only one
might be apocalypse words I'll have to
double check so we've got either one or
two left
um don't know if we're gonna do that
next or if we're gonna steer away into
another one but I do think we're gonna
wrap up this universe we're gonna keep
going after but uh do like a ranking
video and it's been really interesting
to like feel the different Vibes and I'm
really curious how this one went over
because I know like I didn't love the
original take of Wonder Woman the new 52
when they introduced her in this post
Flashpoint Universe was not for me but
they fixed well quippy but also like the
earnestness wasn't Earnest it was like
arrogant
um looking down as a god remember she
would like show at me like these humans
I was like it's Wonder Woman she loves
humans like it felt so wrong it felt so
much Detachment yeah she was just like a
warrior fights and I was like who is
this
[Music]
it was literally someone that left
everything you've loved behind to
protect the people you're judging
arrogantly like who are you yeah and I
get there's different tags there's
different different ages in 52 whatever
but like it was not Wonder Woman sure
like there are some things that are the
core of a character that like the
archetype is vital to make the character
who the character is and for me it's
Batman doesn't shoot people and for me
it's Larkin loves helping people and for
me it's Wonder Woman Loves humanity and
so it was so weird when some of these
were like we're gonna do the opposite
yeah so I I just really made me happy no
totally totally totally because yeah it
still gets all the cool stuff that you
want and there's even some humor
involving Diana yeah but yeah it really
feels like spiritually on point and I
mean you would know certainly with
greater context than an eye but yeah
that that it never really even those
earlier installments I was kind of like
oh used to this take on Wonder Woman and
if I'm saying that then yeah that seems
off yeah it must be a little bit uh
outside the box and I'm glad Rosario got
to come back and like do the Justice
thing she she's always been great it was
good to see her playing the Wonder Woman
that I think of as Wonder Woman yeah in
this context yeah absolutely oh really
Doug this uh definitely one of my top
tier ones I uh I'm really excited to see
how it ends 2019 you know we're catching
up to modern day I'm also curious like
when this universe ends how things take
off from it like what is everything just
separate it's all you know I love not
knowing this I also love that I didn't
know that villain I didn't know um
Silver Silver Swan Silver Swan didn't
know silver swine so this was fun for me
as a comic fan to like enjoy something
completely removed except for my level
Wonder one so yeah this was delightful
delightful dope all right well that is
gonna do it for this episode of man that
was cool uh watching the DC animated
movies but rather enjoying them we've
got one left in this continuity and then
uh we're gonna keep journeying through
so let us know in the comments which you
want us to watch next very excited to do
a koi's comic corner with John I haven't
done that since the first one Wolverine
since Wolverine way back in the days
we're gonna be ranking them together
absolutely uh probably gonna do one
where it's just the the that universe
and then when we're done one where it's
all 50 whatever of them which is gonna
be insane in 2029 when we get to it when
we dude it's gonna be a four hour video
that's right but we're not I'm not
editing it uh but yeah so uh next up is
either gonna be the end of this
continuity or something else entirely
we'll find out but leave a comment below
remember liking this is how we know you
in fact liked this sharing this is how
we get to keep making them because that
shows that you guys are in fact liking
them before we go let's do a patron of
the day shout out
we're gonna give it up to David Gandy
because that name sure is Handy and man
oh Mandy do I like a nice name that
rhymes with candy uh I really enjoy your
name David Gandy I hope it has served
you well I hope you've given it honor as
Diana has given her the mascara honor I
love that Diana Prince is a princess but
since her last name is Prince it allows
a certain tone of regality it also
allows the name to both be uh neutral
sexually but like as in like sex male or
female but I've also always liked that
like Diana Prince is a strong masculine
name for a very strong feminine woman I
think it's a really interesting uh
dichotomy of how we like label things
like we we are working on changing
actress to just actor because it's one
who acts not necessarily like stewardess
and I've always thought Diana Prince for
a character from the 60s was a really
like Progressive name and concept so I
wanted to give some love to another very
cool name which is David Gandy uh and uh
we appreciate you being a patron we
appreciate you as ever being a super
sexy reject and uh thank you absolutely
and you know what you know what yeah you
know what that rhymes with what do you
got add a candy add a candy David Gandy
doing the DC continuity work good call
excellent rap out we will see you soon
for the next one
foreign